[Music]
a pizza delivery man turned bomber a
religious cult based around dieting and
cannabis farmers killed by bigfoot grab
your popcorn the world of true crime is
stranger than fiction and you can stream
these documentaries today based on the
book of the same name this five-part
documentary series revolves around
jeffrey mcdonald a green beret army
surgeon mcdonald is sent to prison for
killing his two young daughters and his
pregnant wife the documentary utilizes
reenactments of what potentially
happened based on trial transcripts
audio and news coverage any good true
crime documentary should be able to keep
the viewer guessing even if the
information presented is public record
it's a fascinating and stylistic look at
a decades old case that still has people
debating the innocence of jeffrey
mcdonald
woody allen's alleged sexual abuse of
his daughter had been a well-known topic
well before this hbo documentary series
came out but upon release allen vs
pharaoh introduced many new eyes to the
complicated and often disturbing actions
of the once celebrated director the
series features old home videos and
various interviews with family members
most damning being dylan farrow allen's
accuser it's a very unpleasant look at a
very disturbing and murky situation
directed by skye borgman and originally
released in 2017 abducted in plain sight
focuses on the horrific kidnappings of
jan broberg felt on two separate
occasions jan was abducted by her
neighbor robert birchdoll during the
1970s based on jan's memoir stolen
innocence the details explained in the
documentary range from the confounding
to the downright sickening i felt like i
was one of his children
it's a story predicated upon unhealthy
obsession manipulation and repulsive
actions that impacted an entire family
many viewers and commentators cannot
believe just how naive the brobergs were
but such is the case with most true
crime it is real and we wish it weren't
we can safely assume that most people
who've watched amanda knox likely spent
significant portions of it yelling at
the screen following the murder of her
roommate meredith kircher amanda knox
studying in italy would be blamed for
the crime nox's arrest was highly
publicized and was portrayed with very
little nuance by italian media she was
painted as a monster the documentary
showcases her four-year incarceration in
italian prison before eventually being
acquitted by the supreme court of
causation it's not only a shocking true
story about a tragic murder but how
dangerous the court of public opinion
can be
what's important for me to say is just
thank you to everyone
who's believed in me
sometimes the most heinous crimes can
occur right under our noses leaving us
none the wiser until it's too late told
via the use of archived family footage
text messages and law enforcement
recordings we learned the story of the
watts family murders the documentary for
the sake of dramatic pacing doesn't
reveal the truth of chris watts the
father having committed the crimes until
the latter half of the film it's a
haunting look at just how families can
fall apart and the most heinous crimes
can occur in peaceful suburbia
audrey and daisy tells the tragic story
of teenagers audrey pont and daisy
coleman the documentary looks at the
rampant cyber bullying and abuse the
girls were subject to following their
sexual assaults and the police
investigations that followed in a day
and age where stories of cyberbullying
online harassment and doxxing are
becoming more and more commonplace in
real life audrey and daisy stands out as
essential viewing the film first debuted
at the 2016 sundance film festival but
would achieve a widespread release later
that year on netflix
a strange dark story involving
large-scale theft fake identities
elaborate cons and even a supernatural
element bad vegan is a hard to believe
but totally true documentary series that
began long ago in a place of good
intentions and stated purity sarma
melangalis used to run pure food and
wine a highly regarded new york city
restaurant where everything on the menu
was both vegan and organic things went
downhill when melangalas married shane
fox and brought him into the business he
wasn't really a curious businessman with
an interest in healthy sustainable
living he was actually a con artist
named anthony stranges who somehow
convinced his wife to illegally hand
over millions of dollars from pure food
and wines coffers into his personal
accounts because he claimed he could use
the money to entice mystical forces into
granting her dog eternal life
born on the something awful forums of
the 2010s slenderman quickly became a
widespread symbol of homegrown internet
horror sadly his legacy will always be
intertwined with the unfortunate story
of anissa wire and morgan geyser the
documentary details how the duo stabbed
their friend paige and lightner 19 times
and left her for dead in the woods yeah
i shouldn't be alive i really shouldn't
after what happened
in the latter half of the documentary it
shows how the two despite their young
age were tried and convicted as adults
for their actions it's a fascinating and
sobering look at not only the rise of
the slenderman mythos but also at an
unfortunate crime
sad sordid and horrific captive audience
a real american horror story will haunt
viewers with its harrowing tale of a
family that endured unspeakable crimes
both as victims and as helpless
outsiders the story begins in 1972 when
seven-year-old stephen steiner
disappears from near his home in merced
california while the worst was predicted
by many steven was actually living with
his captors for getting most details of
his old life and old family which he was
reunited with at the age of 14. his
high-profile kidnapping case captivated
the region but things took a major turn
when it was revealed the area had also
been terrorized by steven's brother
carrie who is by all accounts a vicious
serial killer
you know bad things happen to everybody
but
for our family
it's unreal
in the world of documentary filmmaking
there is perhaps no name more respected
than ken burns and for good reason from
topics such as complicated wars to
important historical figures the man has
seemingly covered it all released in
2012 and co-directed with his daughter
sarah the central park 5 documentary
details the people and events in the
central park jogger case of 1989 it
benefits heavily from burns signature
usage of archival footage and
photographs used to fully immerse the
viewers in the flow of events it's as
important to story now as it was back
then and this documentary showcases it
perfectly and with ample craftsmanship
cocaine cowboys the kings of miami a
six-part netflix documentary series
tells the story of sal magluta and
willie falcone the duo's actions are
still regarded as one of florida's most
well-known cocaine operations the series
showcases their reign as drug kingpins
of miami from their rise to the top to
their eventual fall if you are a fan of
narcos or breaking bad this tightly
edited true story is most definitely for
you
with the title like don't with cats it
should be obvious that some horrific
things happen to cats in this series the
sickening actions of luca magnata
sparked a widespread internet manhunt
spurred on by a group of dedicated
internet users throughout this
three-part series it's shown just what
luca did and how far people went to
catch him the series through energetic
editing and slick pacing shows just how
sick and depraved people can be but also
the tenacity of amateur sleuths
evil genius the true story of america's
most diabolical bank heist details the
death of brian wells which occurred
during what many referred to as the
pizza bomber case this is due to wells a
pizza delivery man being forced to
commit the crime with a bomb strapped to
his neck it's a story you'd swear
sounded 100 like hollywood fiction but
it's real and this documentary discusses
it from every unbelievable angle it's
loaded with actual footage and images of
the shocking events as well as audio
recordings and sobering testimonials
kendrick johnson a student at lowndes
high school was found dead inside of a
rolled up gym mat back in 2013. director
jason pollock and his team crafted a
documentary that takes a harsh look at
the strange circumstances around
kendrick's death through interviews with
kendrick's family and friends it paints
a clear picture of who he was before his
untimely death the film also follows the
subsequent cover-up serving as a hard
reminder of just how one-sided and
racist the justice system can be it's a
story about kendrick's family seeking
some form of justice for kendrick that
sadly may never come our family would
get together every day and we went down
the lounge county courthouse and stood
there and we asked what if this was your
child
fire fraud unravels the inside story of
the infamous fire festival's spectacular
collapse told by some of the people who
helped promote and set up the 2017
non-starter of an event fire fraud is
both a step-by-step account of how
everything that could go wrong did as
well as a true crime documentary
unveiling just how much of an intricate
and bold scam the whole thing may have
been organizers promised a weekend-long
festival of a-list acts and luxurious
accommodations instead they stranded
paying customers on an island with no
food or water i love you now die the
commonwealth versus michelle carter is a
two-part documentary focusing on the
death of conrad roy split into two parts
the prosecution and the defense the
documentary goes into detail about how
michelle carter's texts influenced roy's
suicide the documentary doesn't choose
to fully paint michelle as a villain
never condoning her actions but offering
elaborations on her mental state it's
far from a pleasant watch but it's still
a riveting look at a tragic and
complicated situation in which there
were no true winners
all begone in the dark centers around
the golden state killer a man who
terrorized california throughout the
1970s and 1980s and eluded capture for
decades
this man is considered to have an
extremely violent potential
but i'll be gone in the dark isn't just
about his crimes it's also about the
tireless efforts of pioneering true
crime blogger author and victim rights
crusader michelle mcnamara who finally
brought the golden state killer to
justice through her exhaustive
investigation
if there are three things that can be
classified as inevitabilities it would
most definitely be death taxes and
jeffrey epstein memes however the latter
should never mask just how heinous the
actions of epstein truly were through
this four part series various epstein
survivors are given ample time to go
into detail about their unfortunate
encounters the documentary had actually
been in production prior to epstein's
death and even his arrest having been
made in secret to avoid any
complications even if you are already
aware of epstein and the gist of his
crimes this documentary will serve as
quite the eye-opener as to just how
sickening and severe they were
real estate air robert durst's attorneys
kept him out of prison for years despite
overwhelming evidence and an admission
of guilt that he committed multiple
murders durst is cold and aloof as he
recounts the disappearance of his wife
his close friend's murder which occurred
right before she planned to tell police
durst killed his wife and the fact that
he managed to escape justice for a while
anyway the jinx the life and deaths of
robert durst is a fascinating unsettling
character study made all the more
unnerving when durst basically
incriminates himself
john wayne gacy is among history's most
notorious serial killers his name is
often mentioned in the same
conversations as ted bundy or jeffrey
dahmer peacock clearly understood just
how fascinating gacy is which is why
they released john wayne gacy devil in
disguise in 2021 his crimes are made
even more disturbing when you learn he
was a beloved and trusted member of his
community he was so trusted in fact that
he would often dress as his persona of
pogo the clown for children's birthday
parties
who killed sister kathy that is the
question that the netflix documentary
the keepers asks over the course of its
run time the seven episode documentary
series takes a look at the murder of nun
kathleen cesnik back in the late 60s the
series unfortunately does not end with
the reveal of kathy's killer as they
were never caught it instead showcases
the ripple effect it had on the people
around kathy
the world of professional sports often
serves as the backdrop for many crimes
and shocking actions both big and small
in 2013 the world of professional
football was turned upside down by the
horrific actions of aaron hernandez
during that year's offseason the tight
end was arrested and charged for the
murder of odin lloyd killer inside the
mind of aaron hernandez a three-part
documentary focuses on his conviction
how he's now perceived by his peers and
what factors led to the crime
this documentary focuses on the life and
times of elizabeth carmichael founder of
the 20th century motorcar corporation
creator of a car known as the dale
elizabeth's life was rife with scrutiny
and controversy in regards to her own
past the documentary does a good job at
showcasing carmichael's rise to
prominence while also spotlighting her
various identities marriages and legal
issues
using archival materials such as photos
and audio recordings combined with
animation and photo collages the lady
and the dale paints a succinct picture
of the story
[Music]
not all true crime needs to focus on
death sometimes uncovering deceit and
financial theft is more than enough
founded in 2012 by deanne brady and her
husband mark stidham lularoe is a
multi-level marketing company that sells
women's clothing however this
documentary series released on amazon
prime investigates the company's shady
business practices and exposes it as a
pyramid scheme despite the truth of
their operation being exposed lularoe is
still very much an active business
tonight the company lularoe facing
another lawsuit
the series talks with people inside
lularoe and people on the outside
investigating it the slick editing and
great pacing makes for a great watch
making a murderer is one of the most
noteworthy true crime docu-series of the
past few years it's the story of steve
avery a wisconsin man who falsely served
18 years in prison for the sexual
assault and attempted murder of a woman
who was attacked on a beach it shows
that a documentary series can be just as
if not more enthralling than a fictional
serialized drama as long as the subject
matter is captivating enough clocking in
at two seasons the series is a
meticulously researched and tightly
edited look at the failings of the
justice system
mcmillian's focuses on the now infamous
scam monopoly promotion run by
mcdonald's for over a decade based on
the famous hasbro board game the contest
promised various large cash prizes
none of which were ever won legitimately
it goes into massive detail about this
incredible scam run amok it's far from
graphic or disturbing but it definitely
excels due to its exemplary editing and
stimulating subject matter
if you've seen the act starring joey
king and patricia arquette then you'll
be familiar with the event surrounding
gypsy rose blanchard however this
feature-length documentary shows that
truth is most definitely stranger than
fiction showcasing the story in its
stomach churning entirety i just went on
blind faith that a mother knows best
it details the sinister machinations of
gypsy's mother dede and what led to her
murder in 2015. also detailed in the
documentary is the topic of munchausen
syndrome by proxy how deedy was a
textbook case of it and how gypsy was a
victim of it if you found interest in
the dramatization then this documentary
is most definitely required viewing
in this four part adaptation of the true
crime memoir the most dangerous animal
of all gary l stewart attempts to
identify and locate the biological
parents of who gave him up for adoption
in the course of his research stewart
makes a horrific discovery his father
may have been the zodiac killer the
infamous murderer who terrorized
northern california and taunted police
with cryptograms in the late 1960s
stewart enlists the help of a true crime
author and a private investigator to not
only find his father but possibly also
solve one of american law enforcement's
longest standing murder mysteries
in the mid 80s salt lake city found
itself rocked by a series of bombings
carried by mark hoffman he sent out
three bombs to three separate people in
the salt lake city area resulting in two
deaths the documentary goes into detail
about the various crimes that led to
these bombings including rampant
counterfeiting and forgery if you hadn't
heard of these shocking events then it
would benefit you to give it a watch
mark hoffman doesn't get much mention
alongside figures like ted bundy or
jeffrey dahmer but his story is still an
immensely fascinating one
in 2010 barbara hamburg was savagely
killed just outside her connecticut home
years later with the crime still
unsolved and shrouded in mystery her son
documentarian madison hamburg went
looking for answers with his camera and
a microphone the filmmaker explores the
suspicion brewing inside his own family
perhaps his aunt or sister had something
to do with his mother's death or maybe
his distant divorced father a former
multi-millionaire accused of financial
crimes hamburg's murder could also have
had something to do with a pyramid
scheme called gifting tables the
documentary ultimately raises more
questions than answers but is never less
than fascinating
on november 24th 1971 a man who has
become known as db cooper threatened the
crew and passengers of a commercial
flight and then with the fortune he
demanded on his person parachuted into
the dark chile forest below never to be
seen again the mystery of db cooper
doesn't explore the crime itself so much
as the legend of the hijacker built
around interviews with people who think
they once knew someone who very well
could have been db cooper incognito
these stories are convincing and even
credible
she really matches
i think maybe she is tv
the name richard ramirez alone evokes
memories of a time when los angeles was
paralyzed with fear panic and
uncertainty the infamous night stalker
menaced the city of angels throughout
the 70s breaking entering and committing
sickening crimes of increasing sadism
nightstalker the hunt for a serial
killer is told from the perspective of
the detectives who hunted him and the
few who survived him if you are already
familiar with richard ramirez then this
won't tell you anything new but it's
still a stylistic look at one of
history's most sickening monsters
by exploring multiple time periods and
slowly revealing connections between
them the puppet master hunting the
ultimate con man tells the story of a
con artist as audacious as he is
deceptive in 1993 a bartender named rob
convinced a british college student that
he was actually an mi5 agent a friend's
suicide was related to a campus
terrorist cell and they had to hit the
road for their own safety flash forward
a few years and miles away to the
clifton family where divorced sandra was
romanced by a rich guy named dave who
bought her a car and drove a wedge
between her and her grown children
spoiler rob and dave are the same guy
and he's not in prison
while working as a fringe investigative
journalist in the 1990s david hold house
was privy to an odd and frightening
night in the remote forests of northern
california someone wound up brutally
killed and witnesses were convinced it
was the work of sasquatch or bigfoot the
forest monster of legend in sasquatch
hold house tries to piece together the
who what and why of the bizarre murder
in doing so he delves into a secretive
community in the area where former
hippies dropped out of a society and
illegally farmed marijuana this created
a violent and complicated culture and a
drug war that raged for decades
one more enigmatic and brutal than even
sasquatch
before its netflix release in 2018 the
staircase began life as a french
mini-series by jean javier de la estradi
released in 2004. the series looks at
the trial of michael peterson who was
convicted of killing his wife kathleen
back in 2001. the title is based upon
michael's claim that a drunken kathleen
has fallen down the stairs resulting in
her death the thread of the director was
given the keys to the kingdom in terms
of information and assets being present
for and allowed to film the entirety of
the trial if you have yet to hear the
story of kathleen peterson's death then
this expertly crafted documentary will
provide you with ample information she
was alive when i found her but
barely we could sit here and make claims
that six nine's music itself is a crime
but we'll stick to the stuff we can
prove in court danny hernandez or six
nines rise fall and subsequent comeback
has been a true sight to behold in terms
of ridiculousness and rampant publicity
super villain the making of takashi 69
doesn't shy away from showing just how
much of hernandez's persona was
intentionally built to gain notoriety
which it most definitely did whether you
are a fan of 69's music or not it still
makes for an engaging watch further
cementing his status as modern hip-hop's
super villain
this is one of many true crime stories
so infamous that it made its way into
our consciousness here in the united
states despite taking place overseas
french television producer sophie
toscande
was killed outside her vacation property
in the winter of 1996. it was detailed
that upon the discovery of her body in a
laneway by her house her face was so
disfigured she couldn't be identified by
her neighbors it's a shocking story
steeped in death and controversy about
how a small community was forever
changed by one horrific event
long island is no stranger to tragic and
controversial events one of the most
famous being the amityville murders of
the 70s but the tragic story that more
should know about is the 1992 death of
william ford at the hands of a mechanic
named mark p riley it's a documentary
that discusses not only william's life
and death but the severe injustice that
followed from which the family is still
reeling the documentary directed by
ford's own brother yance is far from an
easy watch but it's a necessary one
especially amidst current racially
charged issues
tales of the grim sleeper showcases the
story of lonnie david franklin jr or the
grim sleeper from 1984 to 2007 in los
angeles california the grim sleeper
claimed 10 victims taking a break from
1988 to 2002. the director talks with
both friends and neighbors about
franklin getting a clearer picture of
who he was it's a very standard true
crime documentary but the subject matter
is intriguing enough to warrant a
recommendation
in march 1990 the isabella stewart
gardner museum located in boston was
robbed for 500 million dollars worth of
art this is a robbery the world's
biggest art heist looks at the
intriguing events and the subsequent
investigations that even today haven't
resulted in the discovery of the
culprits the amount of detail presented
is impressive and thorough and the
series stellar editing makes for a great
watch if you are a fan of heist stories
and were itching for one in the
non-fiction realm then this is a robbery
will most definitely scratch that itch i
keep talking about it
because it's fascinating to me because i
was there
every day countless people use tinder to
find romance but one never really knows
who they'll be spending an evening with
beyond what they offer up about
themselves that dangerous uncertainty is
at the heart of the tinder swindler a
serious documentary about a con artist
who found his marks on the world's most
famous dating app tinder users like
celia fielhoy one of his victims matched
up with a charming good-looking wealthy
businessman of course the titular
swindler isn't really a rich power
player but by the time felhoi and the
man's many other victims figured that
out he'd stolen a lot of their money
through a series of subtle and
sophisticated deceptions
the story of gwen shamblin is one pact
to the brim with deceit toxic behavior
and rampant controversy the way down god
greed and the cult of gwen chamblin is a
simultaneously fascinating and
mind-boggling look at how the cult of
personality based around gwen led to an
actual cult shambling was the founder of
the way down workshop and the remnant
fellowship a bizarre mishmash of
spiritual and dietary guidelines every
time
you want to go to food it may be 15 20
times a day
run to god
champlain's death in a plane crash in
2021 more and more has been uncovered
about who she really was and what truly
went on behind the curtain
who killed garrett phillips tells the
tragic story of a 12 year old guard
phillips who was killed in his own home
back in 2011. the man blamed for the
crime was oral nick hillary who is
accused by the predominantly white
community of potsdam new york the
two-part documentary looks at the
details of the case itself and just what
hillary was subjected to during and
after the trial it's a harsh reminder of
the danger that can be done by the court
of public opinion which in this case was
intensified by immense racial biases
why did you kill me focuses on the death
of 24 year old crystal theobald amidst a
gang shootout back in 2006. it would
later be revealed the gang ambush was
due to a case of mistaken identity
crystal's mother belinda present for the
shootout promised her dying daughter
that she would find who did it her
methods using fake myspace accounts to
find whoever was responsible makes for a
truly engaging documentary it's a
fascinating look at social media's
presence and utilization in homegrown
solving efforts
wild wild country covers the shocking
events concerning the guru bhagwan shri
rajneesh who garnered an immense
following during the 70s and founded the
community of rajneesh param in oregon
this six-part netflix series is packed
to the brim with first-hand accounts and
ample archival footage all used to
shocking effect if the story of bhagwan
shri rajneesh has flown under your radar
we highly recommend giving this one a
watch
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite true crime series are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you